hello everybody part of me hopes that
the slide actually won't work because
they aren't very pretty but anyway about
a year ago I graduated from this very
place MIT and I thought I was fairly
ready to face the world and then I
realized there was a lot of stuff I had
to learn after graduation I got pretty
lucky and I was able to land a job at Al
Jazeera America with these lovely
colleagues they've taught me a lot over
the past year things like how to wear
fake mustaches I swear my fake mustache
looks a lot better now than it did then
but one of the biggest things that I've
probably learned of the past year is how
to talk to people
um so talking to people is something
that I was always able to do if I had a
goal in the conversation so if I was
doing an interview I always knew what I
want to get so I'd be able to talk to
them if I was working on a piece ed or a
project with people I always knew what I
want we always knew what the goal was so
it wasn't hard to talk but it always
made me a little anxious to walk into a
room of people and just do like the
little conversation chitchat thing like
still kind of makes me a little bit
nervous
um so coming from MIT well I'm not gonna
say people from MIT don't know how to
talk because you can see lots of people
from MIT here who can't actually talk
and actually like in my major there's
actually a required class which is
basically dubbed the social skills class
and every January they're one of the
most popular classes you can take is a
class called Charm School which is the
class where they teach you how to ask
someone out teach you how to go on a
date what you do with all those crazy
forks and spoons and plates when you go
to a fancy dinner but I can say that
academic environments where about 80
percent of like 90 percent of the
conversations are about having not slept
for the past three days having not seen
the Sun for the past three days or
quantum mechanics it's not exactly the
same thing as when you go out into the
real world so how did I learn to talk to
people this year well I'm still learning
and I was going to talk about five
lessons but I'm gonna sneak one in
really quickly six because I learned a
really important one tonight don't try
to talk to people when they were
watching the World Cup doesn't work
so back to the actual talk um well I was
prepping this talk I tried to
crowdsource
tips for my friends the do's and don'ts
of talking to people so I asked 544 of
my closest Facebook friends what the
do's and don't should be one of my
friends just answered don't so my other
friends gave me some like more useful
advice things like you know share a
little bit of information about yourself
to build trust set a goal of chronic
conversation smile bring cookies but one
of the things that most of them also
said was I'm terrible at talking to
people I'm an awkward penguin so this
leads to me leads to the first lesson
that I'm going to talk about which is
probably the most important when I've
learned this year most people aren't
totally comfortable just walking up to
strangers and talking to them and that's
okay because everyone else is in the
same boat so lesson number one is stop
thinking that everyone knows how to talk
better than you do the second lesson I
would talk to a talk about is talking to
people requires actual talking so let me
demonstrate imagine you're walking into
a room and you want to be able to
converse with someone but you're
terrified of talking so instead you
might try something like this do you
want to be my new friend you might end
up having just end like okay bye but in
all seriousness talking does require
actual talking a gchat a text or just a
yo isn't really a sufficient so I'm
gonna move on to lesson number three now
that's gonna be a pretty short one this
one's one that I've learned as a
reporter over the past year it's been
pretty important you carry a big camera
and multiple microphones you don't have
to talk to people they will come and
talk to you although sometimes that's
just the yell at you and say to get out
of my face
moving on to lesson number four ask
questions as a journalist has been
really really important for me but also
what I've noticed is that if you don't
like talking to people the more
questions you ask the less you actually
have to talk to them so but just do
remember to actually listen to them and
look them in the eye and actually maybe
ask some questions that are
follow-ups to what they say and lesson
number five finally practice makes
perfect and that's actually part of the
reason why I'm standing up here today
because hopefully I will be talking a
lot over the next couple days and that
leads me to my challenge to you all and
I hope you guys all also will be talking
to each other and hopefully also to me
over the next couple days so maybe by
next year I'll be able to give a talk
like how to make friends in the real
world but in all seriousness
talk to each other and come talk to me
afterwards
[Applause]